a frustration is mounting from business
owners just trying to make ends meet
our next guest knows this all too well
he's been fighting with his governor
to reopen his indoor activity park while
gyms in his area
have been given the green light to
operate at 25
capacity urban air adventure park owner
thomas garcia
joins us now thomas thanks for being
with us so you know we're confused we're
looking at this and we're saying
okay if gyms are allowed to reopen why
is your adventure park any different
have you been able to get any response
on
that i have not i have been talking with
the governor's office for
over six months right now i actually
talked to the governor herself
um the governor from her own mouth has
told me
that she believes that urban air
can keep their guests safe but
she cannot open us because we are in
this close contact recreational facility
category um so she cannot open us
but how is that right that she comes and
says that
hey thomas i think you can keep your
guests safe
but i still can open i still can't open
you
i'll tell you what she should do and
this is what they actually did in
florida i know will you're over in in
florida right now but this is what they
did in florida
the governor actually sent people to
urban air
in florida because they got they got our
40-page plan of our reopening
and they examined what we're doing so
they watched us taking the temperature
of our guests as and employees as they
came in they watched us
uh use our fogging machine to spray an
anti-microbial all over our equipment
they watched our social distancing but
that's how you try
to mitigate coronavirus is you educate
businesses
and you find businesses that are doing
the right thing
and then you try to implement that in
other businesses
that's how you do that not by
restricting them right
thomas it's hard to make sense of
obviously gyms as you pointed out
strip clubs are open in new mexico but
you're not
what is it that's unique about your
business tell us a little more about
what urban air is and why for some
reason it's fallen on the wrong line of
openings and closings
sure so um so we are an indoor active
entertainment venue
and we have such things as climbing
walls we have the only
indoor sky diving in all of new mexico
we have trampolines
we have a zip line so we have a lot of
the
equipment where other other places are
open so gyms are open
rock climbing wall places are open my
daughter goes
to uh gymnastics and she jumps on the
trampoline every time she goes over
there
they are open but we we for whatever
reason
are not open and it's you know we
have 85 really good employees
that work for us that don't have a job
right now
and that's across new mexico it's not
just about
me it's about a whole lot of other
businesses that are just getting
absolutely crushed right now and
and and you know i had a conversation
with
with an employee yesterday that's living
out of a motel right now so we're
actually gonna
help him out we have another location in
littleton we actually talked to him
about actually
um hey temporarily would you mind going
to littleton and helping us there we'll
get you some
uh some full-time housing over your head
wow thomas you know your business
is too unique for a government
bureaucracy to figure it out so they
just say too complicated
you're shut down but we're glad we could
elevate your story of note also
all on one other 154 urban air locations
in america have reopened safely
yours in new mexico is the one that
hasn't been allowed to we hope that
changes very soon we've reached out for
an answer we'll let you know if we get
one
uh thomas garcia appreciate it